rebecca's in orlando florida
hi rebecca welcome to the dave ramsey
show hi dave thanks so much for taking
my call i'm very principal
sure how can we help um i have the
florida prepaid program for both of my
children
and my son doesn't think he's going to
go to college it's not the 529
i have a large irs debt i'm trying to
eradicate and um i was thinking of
taking the money from the florida
prepaid plan to put it towards the irs
debt and then when my daughter's ready
for college i could just cash flow her
how much is in the prepaid plan 23 000.
and how much is the irs debt 55.
what is the irs debt from it's from
three years
um i'm embarrassed to say my daughter
was sick and i was in the middle of a
divorce
and um i i was just trying to keep it on
the table and i hadn't filed for a few
okay so it's just back taxes just back
taxes
you unfiled at all and you must i have
since filed
i mean you must be 1099 or self-employed
uh self-employed yes yeah okay so what
do you make
uh well this year with the pandemic i'll
probably make about 55
maybe 60. that's right i got the irs on
a payment plan
uh no i actually applied for a um
an offer in compromise but i haven't
heard from them yet it's been a very
strong
um you have to you have to be able to
show pulper status
absolutely no income and no assets to
get an oic through
that's one of the great mythologies how
much did you pay for this oic
application
i put it down six thousand dollars oh
man yeah
um okay don't give me more money um
yeah that that's a there's just very
i've been doing this 30 years i've seen
two of those go through
two and uh and in both cases we were
working with a tax attorney
and you prove that they have no assets
at all and no
income and really no potential of income
and so they really believe that you're
virtually financially dead and you're
not you make 55 000
a year so they're going to put you on a
900 year payment plan
all right um i don't cash out kids
uh college funds for debts but the kgb
around your neck the irs after you is
not going away
so yeah i'm doing this
um all right but be forewarned that what
goes with it
the tears that you had a minute ago uh
with the shame of not having filed
because of all the stress and the
horrible things you were going through
you're probably going to have more of
that
feeling because you just use your kids
college fund
to clean up the mess are part of the
mess
and so that's why i almost never tell
someone to use a college fund
uh even though it might make
mathematical sense is because you feel
like a dog using your kids
money that you set aside for them and i
just want to warn you ahead of time
you're going to have that feeling
but it is still the logical thing to do
it's the right thing to do here
uh it is the best thing for your kids
for their mom to get straightened up
and get this get this debt out of her
life because the irs has tremendously
expensive penalties
interest and they have almost unlimited
power to
screw up your life you want to get them
out of your life
believe me it's i i it's the only kind
of debt that
terrifies me for for our clients it
terrifies me
because i've seen what the kgb does to
people
and when they decide they want to get
rough and so i just don't want you on
that
thing and i want you to get with uh one
of our tax elps
and get an installment plan working as
soon as you hear that the oic
went sideways and certainly don't see
you listed on the oic that this college
money exists right
no because there's technically no cash
value and i didn't even think about it
until after i submitted it
oh there's technically cash value when
you cash it out you're getting cash
yeah i guess i didn't yeah i i you know
yeah
if they saw that on the application they
would have grabbed it they would have
said no you're not you're going to give
us that money
so if i'm wrong i'll be happy for you
and the oic comes through and they say
you know we'll settle this 55 000 debt
for 23 000
cash it out and do it but then you've
got to really get in gear
and you got to start working with your
son and your daughter on how they're
going to get their education paid for
they're going to get really good at
taking the act test they're going to get
really good at working their butts off
while they're in school
you're going to pick an affordable
school not an expensive
famous school in state maybe a two-year
program to get
some of the basics out of the way really
cheap all of those kinds of things
yeah that's exactly right and i'm gonna
recommend you be
real vulnerable sit down at the kitchen
table and walk your kids
um through what's happened what we're
gonna do about it
without blaming dad we're not gonna
blame anybody you're gonna take
ownership for this this is a level of
vulnerability
they're to feel this tension on you and
what kids do dave is they absorb that
tension and blame themselves
especially young kids and especially
teenagers so this is a great moment for
an adult to model
hey guys here's what i did to put food
on the table wasn't right here's what
i'm doing to clean it up
here's what we're all going to do
together we're all going to start
budgeting we're all going to lean into
this stuff and is it going to be
uncomfortable oh my gosh
there's going to be some value to your
kids seeing the tears and seeing the
plan
and watching you live out of this thing
and there is a way to make meaning on
the back end of this thing
but those tears will have value it is
not a
conversation that um you portray the end
of the world
no it's a conversation that goes uh i
screwed up and here's what i'm doing and
yeah and there's a redemption there's
we're going to make meaning of this and
things are going to change around here
and we're all going to do this at the
table together
now the good news is things are going to
change the bad news is things
that's right and so the vulnerability is
going to be hard the tier is going to be
real
and the the walking out of this is going
to be tough you still got to come up
with 25 000 other dollars right yeah to
pay this thing off
pandemic or otherwise you got to get
your income up and you got to get this
thing knocked out
fast yep as fast as you possibly can
hang on i'm going to send you a copy of
anthony o'neill's book debt free degree
and that'll help the kiddos start to
think that way and you start to think
that way because you're going to be cash
flowing this
a b they are too going to be playing
along that's right um
see we got 25 000 more to clean up with
the irs
if i'm wrong and i wish i was but i'm
not